ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES BELL
BURGESS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG DALLY DODD TO ROSS SO
GALGIANI. HE'S GUN. GROWS
HERTZBERG HELLO WEST SO TALK.
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MAKE.
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCK
MORALE NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN NUMBER
WHY CAL SKI WINNER WILK. GREAT
A CORPSMAN PRESENT WITH A
MEMBER IN OUR GET BR THE RAIL
AND THE PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LETTING PRAYER MORNING OUR
GUEST THIS IS BRIDGE A- RSM
AFTER WHICH REMAIN AS WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG BY
SENATOR. BLOCK. GOTTA
FAITHFULNESS WE COME TO YOU AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS DAY. AND
FIND OURSELVES EATING TO BEGIN
AGAIN ON NEW PROJECTS NEW
IDEAS. AND RENEW DISCUSSIONS.
WE ARE IN NEED OF YOUR GRACE TO
UNSETTLE AND RE DIRECT OUR
HEARTS. WE ARE IN NEED OF YOUR
POWER TO RECAP AND SUSTAIN OUR
PASSION FOR JUSTICE. WE ARE IN
NEED OF YOUR WISDOM TO GUIDE US
IN SHAPING THE FUTURE. WE ARE
IN NEED OF YOUR LOVE THAT WE
MIGHT RECOGNIZE THE EVER
PRESENT POSSIBILITY FOR CHANGE
AND CONVERSION AND GROWTH. WE
BELIEVE YOUR SPIRIT IS AT WORK
IN OUR WORLD AND IN OUR MIDST.
GIVE US I IS A FAITH. THAT WE
MIGHT SEE SUCH WONDERS IN OUR
MIDST AND THE COURAGE TO LIVE
IN HOPE AMEN. COLLEAGUES AND
GUESTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA READY AGAIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. AS A. SAN.
IS YEAH FOR ALL. NOW MEMBERS
WILL BE MOVING TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. CENTER Y. CASKEY ARE
YOU READY FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
AT THE MOMENT MAJORITY LEADERS
TO ASK YOU KNOW MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
NORMALLY DON'T GET UP. AND DO
THESE TYPE OF THINGS. IT MAKING
IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT BUT I
THOUGHT IT WAS SPECIAL TODAY
FOR THE SENATE TO JOIN ME IN
ACKNOWLEDGING THE MY OUTGOING
CHIEF OF STAFF DIRECTOR NOW-
THERE CAN AS WELL MIMI ARE HERE
SOME BACK TO ME I THANK. DEREK
MY CHIEFS YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
STILL KNOWN AS FAMILY MEMBER Y.
CASKEY. AND AT THE TOP. THAT I
HIRED HIM I DIDN'T. THAT I HAD
ONE THAT SHE OF STAFF STAFF
JACKPOT. YOU KNOW. RIGHT NOW I
IT WAS ONLY AFTER I HIM DAY OUT
THAT HE WAS A LAKER FAN THAT HE
WAS A YOU KNOW AT THE FLOOD THE
TIE I'M HE WAS IT. YOUR FRIEND
AND WAS A GREEN BAY PACKER FAN
AND WE GOT LEE STADIUM AND I
THE TEN SENATE DISTRICT BUT-
THEN NOW I ALSO KNEW THAT HE
WAS MULTI TALENTED THAT. HE HAD
REPORTED THE CON FRAZIER. SO
WITH THIS MEANT THAT BROUGHT A
TO TROVE OF INFORMATION AND
COMMAND OVER YOU KNOW CAL
RECYCLING AND RESOURCES WERE AT
THAT TIME WERE IN DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION AND DUGGAR DO OIL
AND GAS AND GEO GEOLOGIC MINING
ACTIVE. FIVE CURIOUSLY. FORM IS
LIKE FRIEND PAT WIN SOME. HERE
WHOSE NAME WILL GO ON NO I AND
SPOKE. AS ME AT FROM TO TIME IF
COULD BUY DEAR FOR A COUPLE OF
HOURS THIS TO GET THEIR LEAD.
AND TIPPED SHAPE WHICH IS NICE
BEYOND THOSE AT. I CAN TO RELY
ON HIM FOR SO MUCH. YOU KNOW HE
TURNED MY- INTO. AND AMBITIONS
INTO REALITY HE TURNED MY
PASSION. FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEGISLATION
PRIORITIES INTO LAW. ME TURN MY
BAD JOKES INTO LAUGHS. BUT
TODAY I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY CHIEF OF STAFF IN THIS
RESOLUTION WORSE AT RISEN WITH.
GOTCHA THIS IS. OKAY FOR HIS
DEDICATION TO THE LOW. TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND AS A
PUBLIC SERVANT FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND FORCE TALENTS IN
MANAGING NOT ONLY MY OFFICE BUT
NOW HE MANAGE ME AS MUCH AS
THAT COULD BE DONE RIGHT TO
PLEASE JOHN JOIN ME IN HONORING
DIRECTOR NOW THE WIZARD OF MY
EYES AS HE STARTS HIS NEXT
EXCITING CHAPTER DIRECTOR.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO SENATOR NIELSEN'S
A JOURNEY MEMORY CENTER. MADAM
PRESIDENT AND LADIES AND THE
SENATE. VERY HONORED TODAY. TO
BE ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ONE OF
OUR OWN. WHO SERVED IN THIS
AUGUST INSTITUTION A FEW YEARS
AGO. HE DID A TWO YEAR TERM
HERE ON THE STATE SENATE HE WAS
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS CHAIRMAN.
IT WAS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE AT THE TIME. THEN HE
WAS ELECTED TO A FOUR YEAR TERM
AND THEN A ANOTHER. FOUR YEAR
TERM. AND THEN HE BECAME
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE ELECTION OF
RONALD REAGAN. AND YOU GOT TO
KNOW. THAT GREAT MAN. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR PRO TEM. EARLY
TEN GOVERNOR LANE COLLECTED
KERN LOCKERS. WHO VERY HELPFUL
IN GETTING US IN CONTACT WITH
THE HARM HER FAMILY. IT KIND OF
SOMETHING THAT IS A LESSON OF
THE RESPECT. FOR THE
INSTITUTION AND THE OFFICE.
THAT WE GET TO RECOGNIZE PEOPLE.
AND IT'S KNOWN IN A NONPARTISAN
WAY. JOHN HARMER WAS. A MAN OF.
FROM UTAH THE FAMILY I BELIEVE
THEY HAD NINE. IN THE FAMILY.
VERY ACTIVE IN THE CHURCH. AND
JOHN. LAUNCH THE CAREER YOU
SERVED IN THE NAVY. AND THEN A
HAND GUN AND AFFECTION THAT IS
AFFECTED MANY OF US IN NEW
DECIDED TO. THROW CAUTION TO
THE WIND AND- SUBJECT HIMSELF
TO THE ABUSE OF BE AN INTELLECT
OFFICIAL. I OFTEN SAY THAT WHEN
THE SWEARING IN OCCURS AND
SWEARING AT BEGINS. WELL JOHN
SERVE NOBLY. WITH ONE OF OUR
GREATEST GOVERNOR'S. AND AS
WELL A PRESIDENT. HE WROTE A
BOOK OUR FRIEND ALEC VASSAR OUR.
INSTITUTIONAL HISTORIAN.
BROUGHT TO BOOK TODAY THAT JOHN
WROTE CALLED WE DARE NOT FAIL.
THAT'S AND THOSE ARE PROPHETIC
WORDS THE SPEAK TO A GREAT
CHALLENGE THAT WE ALL FACE IN
LIFE. JOHN ENJOYED HIS TENURE
HERE. AND HE'S CERTAINLY IS
FRIENDSHIP AND THIS TENURE.
WITH RONALD REAGAN. HE MADE HIS
MARK. FOR HIS COUNTRY. FOR A
STATE. THERE'S FAMILY AND REYES
FAITH. AT LAST THAT WE
RECOGNIZE AND ACKNOWLEDGE TODAY.
ONE OF OUR OWN JOHN HARMER.
WITH THIS ARE HIS SON JOHN. AND
TWO OF. SENATOR HARMER'S GRAND
CHILDREN PIPER IN CANADA.
THERE'S A GREAT FAMILY AND I'M
PRIVILEGED TO. BE THERE ARE
SENATOR EVEN. SO THAT'S ANOTHER
CONNECTION. BUT I WOULD THEN AS
WELL MEMBERSHIP. LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT THE MARIAM THAT
WE MAY GIVE TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS. AND I TELL THE STORY
WHEN WE PRESENT THESE THAT YOU
KNOW THIS HAS. THE STANDING OF
THE ENTIRE STATE SENATE BEHIND.
WHEN YOU GIVE TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS I'M THERE WITH YOU.
THERE WITH ME. AND THAT'S
ANOTHER TESTIMONY TO THE
GREATNESS OF THIS INSTITUTION
THAT WE LOVE. SENATOR JOHN
HARDER TENET GOVERNOR JOHN
HARPER LIVED AND LOVED MAY
REMEMBER HIM TODAY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MR MAJORITY LEADER.
WHEN SPEAKING WITH MISTER
MAJORITY OF THANK YOU MISTER UP
PRESIDENT. I MET SENATOR AND
SUBSEQUENTLY- LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR JOHN ARMOR WHEN I WAS
NINETEEN YEARS OLD. HE WITH THE
SENATE IN THIS HOUSE. AND THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THE TIME
MENTAL TROUBLE. LEFT THE JOB IN
BY REAGAN APPOINTED HIM IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS AS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR. I WAS A YOUNG
NINETEEN YEAR OLD KID DRIVING A
FELLOW BUT A MEMBER OF AN M.
DONNELLY. WHO IS A CENTER FOR
THE TWENTY NINE CENTRAL
DISTRICT TO WAS THE NOMINEE OF
MY PARTY. SO I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY IS A YOUNG MAN TO.
MEET WITH A GOVERNOR ARMOR. AND
GET TO KNOW ME A LITTLE BIT. I
DIDN'T AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT
I EVER SAID. BUT HEY THIS AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT. THIS IS WHAT
I TAKE AWAY FROM THIS JOB AND I
THINK ALL OF US TO SO MANY OF
US HAVE FANCY TITLES IN THESE
JOBS BUT FUNDAMENTALLY WE HAVE
TO INTEGRATE OUR VALUES INTO
WHO WE ARE. AND EVEN THOUGH I
WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE AND I WAS
THE YOUNG KID DRIVE ANY ALWAYS
IT WAS VERY GRACIOUS TO ME
ALWAYS VERY NICE ALWAYS CARED
AND WAS DECENT FELLOW WE BEAT
THEM PRETTY BIG IN THAT
ELECTION THAT WAS A GOOD
BECAUSE WE'RE ON THE WOMEN'S
SIDE. EVEN IN EVEN AFTER HE
LOST HE ALWAYS IS GRACIOUS ANY
HE KNEW MY NAME BUT I JUST
THINK THAT. WE'VE ALL HAD THE
SIX. YOU KNOW WE ARE. DEMOCRATS
AND WE ARE REPUBLICANS AND- I
REMEMBER HIM IN THE OTHER HOUSE
WITH GREEN PARTY FOLKS. BUT THE
END OF THE DAY WERE PUBLIC
SERVANTS WERE SENATORS. WE
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S WHAT I LEARNED FROM
JOHN ARMOR HE WAS A VERY
GRACIOUS GUY AND I WANT TO
JOINT THE JOINT IN THE
ADJOINING IS NOT. THANK YOU.
MOVING OUT MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING NOW TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT ONE- SEE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE ITEM TWENTY
A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY TWENTY
FOURTH THROUGH THE TWENTY
SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE IN CONDITION OF
THE FILE I. I'M NOT SURE IF
THIS IS APPROPRIATE- HOW I'M TO
GO ABOUT IS NOT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME. THE
APPROPRIATE TIME RIGHT BEFORE
WE GO TO MOVE TO GERMANY. OKAY
WELL CALLING YOU BEFORE WE COME
THE PRO TEND TO CLOSE THIS OUT
THANK YOU SIR. NOW MOVING ONTO
CONSIDERATIONS THE DAILY FILE.
BEGIN WITH SENATE THIRD READING
CLERK PLEASE READ. WHAT. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALAN RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION DAYS. CENTER ALLEN
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS- I
SERVICE SHARE OUR SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE AND I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SR SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH
IS IN RECOGNITION OF CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION DAYS
WHICH- HAS TAKEN PLACE OVER THE
LAST THREE HERE AT THE STATE
CAPITOL. I WITH A COMBINED
CONTRIBUTION A HUNDRED THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN OVER ONE MILLION
INDIVIDUALS EMPLOYED IN OUR
STATE. AVIATION AND AEROSPACE
INDUSTRIES ARE MAJOR DRIVERS OF
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY. OUR STATE
HISTORY MUCH OF THE HISTORY OF
THIS. OF ITS OF ITS MIDDLE
CLASS IS MANY WAYS TIED TO
ADVANCES IN OUR SPACE. DEFENSE
AND AVIATION. ASIANS
ORIGINATING OUT OF AEROSPACE
RESEARCH MUCH OF IT CONDUCTED
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDE WEATHER FORECASTING
WIRELESS. AND LONG DISTANCE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPUTER
JOYSTICKS WATER FILTERS THE
ARTIFICIAL HEART. THE ELECTRIC
CAR. WE DO REMAIN AN EPICENTER
FOR COMMERCIAL ACADEMIC IN
GOVERNMENT RELATED AEROSPACE
ACTIVITY. HOWEVER WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE INDUSTRY FACES SOME
COMPETITIVE CHALLENGES
INCLUDING FEDERAL BUDGET
REDUCTIONS TAX AND REGULATORY
CONSTRAINTS AND RAPIDLY AGING
WORKFORCE. HIGHER CHEN
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR OUR ECONOMY OUR
AVIATION AND AEROSPACE FOLKS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SR SEVENTY SEVEN TODAY.
ANY FOR LATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. HI BEL.
PORGES HI BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO BY CHANGE. DELHI.
DODD HI THERE ALSO. GALGIANI HI
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GREW. HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL. HI WES SO HI.
HI JACKSON JOE. I LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MOM.
MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE. BY ME.
HI I PORTANTINO. HI RALPH HI. I
SKINNER BY STERN. BY NUMBER BY
Y. KO SKI HI. BY WILK HI. CLARK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BELL. HI JANE. DALLY THEY'RE
ALSO. JACK MONNING. THE CLERK
ARE CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME CHIANG. DALLY HI
THERE ALSO. JACKSON MONNING THE.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO NO VOTES
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM FIFTEEN CLERK
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
EIGHTY BY SENATOR ATKINS
RELATIVE TO THE STANDING RULES
OF THE SENATE FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
MADAM PRO TEM. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS S. R. EIGHTY
IMMENSE A STANDING RULE TWELVE
OF THE SENATE TO INCREASE THE
MEMBERSHIP. ON THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE FROM
THIRTEEN TO FIFTEEN I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
NONE I THINK NINE CLARK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES I
TELL HI GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI
CAMBIADO HI CHIANG THE ALLEY.
DODD HI THERE ALSO. GALGIANI HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROVE.
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WES SO
TALK HI JACKSON. JOAN BY LEYVA
I MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL. MARK
MITCHELL I MONNING HI MORE LOT.
MORALE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO- AYE ROTH HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER OUR EYES STERN. HI
I'M BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER. HI WILK HI. CLARK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS CHIANG. SALLY THEY'RE
ALSO. GROW JACKSON. MORE LOCK.
MORALE. COURT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE FINAL TIME. PORGES
CHIANG. DALLY THEY'RE ALSO.
GROW JACKSON MORE LOCK. MORALE.
HI THIRTY ONE KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED NOW I
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING ITEM NINETEEN
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
RELATIVE TO ROSA PARKS DAY.
THERE BRADFORD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY IN. RECOGNITION TO
PRESENT ACR ONE FIFTY SIX IN
RECOGNITION OF ROSA PARKS DAY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE SHOULD ALL AGREE THAT MS
PARKS IS BY ONE THE GREATEST
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS TO HAVE
LIVED. ACR ONE FIFTY SIX
DECLARES FEBRUARY FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY AS THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
PARKS TO IN CALIFORNIA MS PARKS
WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY FOURTH IN.
NINETEEN THIRTEEN IN THE SOUTH
AND BECAME ONE OF THE MOST
RENOWNED PIONEERS IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WHEN SHE
REFUSED TO GIVE UP HER SEAT TO
A WHITE MAN ON THE BUS. THAT
ACT OF CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE LED
TO THE MONTGOMERY BOYCOTT AND
REALLY THE IMPETUS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN THE LATE
FIFTIES AND THE SIXTIES. AFTER
HERS HER STORK DAY MISS PARKS
DEDICATED HER LIFE THE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND EQUALITY FOR ALL SHE
WENT ON TO BE A LOYAL STAFFER
TO FORMER CONGRESSMAN JOHN.
CONYERS AND MANY MIGHT NOT KNOW
SHE WAS A PART TIME CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT SHE SPENT HER WINNERS
IN CALIFORNIA FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS I BELIEVE RESIDING IN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LH DISTRICT- UP
UNTIL A FEW YEARS BEFORE. HER
PASSING. ON FRIDAY FEBRUARY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE OFFICIALLY-
PROCLAIMED ROSA PARKS DAME
MORALIZING HER CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. ACR
ONE FIFTY SIX CREEK CAMERA
RATES THE TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OR ROSA PARKS DAY MPS. FURTHER
HOMMAGE TO OUR COMMITMENT
DEDICATION TO THIS NATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU CENTER BRADFORD. SEEING NO
OTHER MIKE'S RAISED A CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI CAN I BATES HI BEL
I. HI BRADFORD HI COUPLE YET I
CHIANG DELHI AYE DODD HI THERE
ALSO. GALGIANI I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I. HERTZBERG HI HILL I
WES SO. HI ARE TAUGHT. I
JACKSON. JONES I HI MCGUIRE. I
AM I HI MONNING. HI MORE LOCK
HI MORALE HI NIELSEN HI PAN HI
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO I
STERN HI I'M BURKE I CAL SKI HI
I. HI WILK HI I. PLEASE CALL
THE APPS MEMBERS. CHIANG THE
ROSS. THROWS JACKSON. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED NOW THIS
IS APPROPRIATE TIME FOR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER
MITCHELL GET A COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT. MISTER PRESIDENT
I INDEED DO COLLEAGUES THE
pCOMMITTEE WILL CONVENE THIS
AFTERNOON IMMEDIATELY UPON A
GERMAN THE FLOOR SESSION WILL
BE HERE AT MEETING- THIS WEEK
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
THANK YOU. SEEING NOT OTHERS
NOW WE MEMBERS WE WILL RETURN
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
IS THE PROPER TIME TO DO A
JOURNEY MEMORIES- SENATOR PAN.
ARE YOU PREPARED. PLEASE ENTER
PAN THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS- I RISE TODAY IS VICE
CHAIR OF THE FEI LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO GERMAN MEMORY OF
KELLY NAKAHARA. CONSTITUENTS
CENTER. TO PASS AWAY FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH ONE. TWENTY TWENTY HE
WAS SEVENTY TWO LET'S NOT IS
BEST KNOWN FOR REVOLUTION A
ROLE AS LIEUTENANT NURSE KELLY
YAMATO ON THE HIT TELEVISION
SERIES MASH. WHO BROUGHT A
POSITIVE LIGHT TO ASIAN
AMERICAN ACTORS AND ACTRESSES
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES WHEN THERE WEREN'T
VERY MANY. US MASH WAS THE
CLAIMS. CERTAIN THE MOBILE ARE
HOSPITAL CREE WAR SERIES RAN
FROM NINETEEN SAID TWO TO A
THREE ON CBS. IN A PARTICULARLY
MEMORABLE SCENE KELLY REVEALS
HER FEELINGS FOR THE SHOW'S
MAJOR CHARACTER THE- WOMANIZING
SURGEON HAWKEYE PIERCE I THINK
PLAY BY OUR ALAN. SCALDING HOT
FOR HAVE SIZE EVERY NEW EXCEPT
HER. FOR YOUR FOR IT FOR YOUR
FOR SHEET HIM I HAPPEN TO HAVE
A FENCE SENSE OF ABOUT THE PER.
AND I'M MORE SENSOR LIKE YOU
BELIEVE I ALSO SING AND PLAY
THE GUITAR NUMBER TO TAP DANCE
ON THE TOP OF ALL THAT I HAPPEN
TO BE CUTE CELL. SB CERTAIN WAS
MORE THAN A CUTE. WHEN KELLY
SPOKE WITH NPR TWENTY SO. SHE
SAID THAT STILL. PEOPLE COMING
UP TO HER. AND SAID THAT SHE
WAS THE FIRST ROLE MODEL THEY
HAD OF AN ASIAN WHO WASN'T
JUST. FOR TRADE. AS AN ASIAN.
BUT AS A PERSON. ON THE SHOW.
LOOKING BACK A ROLE DECADES
LATER WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
KELLY'S PRESENCE ON MASH WAS
INSPIRATIONAL REVOLUTIONARY TOO
MANY VIEWERS. AND BESIDES HER
SUCCESSFUL CAREER AS AN ACTRESS
IT WAS ALSO WATER COLOR ON
ARTIST A SINGER AND AN ACTIVE
RESIDENT IN PASADENA CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND.
THE TWO CHILDREN AND FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED RETURNED
IN HER MEMORY OF THIS GROUND
ACTRESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PASSED CENTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MISTER A PRESIDENT A
MEMBER AND THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR
A RECOGNIZING CALLIE- AS HAS
BEEN SAID SHE WAS A LONG TIME
pPASADENA RESIDENTS. AN
APPOINTEE OF THE MAYOR FOR
EIGHT YEARS ON THE ARTS
COMMISSION AND MY PREDECESSOR A
SENATOR JACK'S GOT SELECTED ONE
OF HER OIL PAINTINGS TO
REPRESENT HIS DISTRICT AT THE
TIME TO BE DISPLAYED IN CAPITAL
SO SHE MADE. PASADENA PROUD SHE
MADE ALL OF US PROUD AND IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE CHEN IN HER
MEMORY AND THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT TODAY. KEY CENTER
PORTANTINO. CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN AND THE
MEMORY OF A GREAT CALIFORNIA
GREATS LEADER GREAT ELECTED
OFFICIAL THAT IN THE PERSON OF
READ ALL WALTERS MS WALTERS WAS
A TRAIL BLAZING AFTER AMERICAN
WOMAN WHO ADVOCATED FIERCELY.
ALL ON THE SENJU SCHOOLBOY AS
AS DAILY CITY COUNCIL SHE
SERVED ON LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD FROM. SEVENTY NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE TO NINETEEN NINETY
ONE AND THEN ON LA CITY COUNCIL
FROM NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. MS WALTERS
PAST WEEK AT THE TWO AGE OF
EIGHTY NINE YEARS OF AGE. RITA
WAS IN CHICAGO ILLINOIS PLACE.
AUGUST FOURTEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY SHE WAS THE OLDEST OF
FIVE CHILDREN HER FATHER WAS
FATHER HEARING YOU WORKED AS A
PULLMAN PORTER AND HER MOTHER
BETTER CLEAN HOUSES. FUTURE
LEADER WAS TERM TO GET IT
EDUCATION BEING AMONG THE FIRST
IN A GRADE A LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MS WALTERS ALL TO MAKE
OUR TO WAITED FROM SHAW
UNIVERSITY IN NORTH CAROLINA-
EARNED. HER MASTER'S DEGREE IN
MINISTRY THIS ADMINISTRATION
SHALL LIVE. THIS WILL BE HER
POLITICAL CAREER BY RUNNING FOR
LAWCENTER BOARD TWICE- BEFORE-
LOSING TWICE I SHOULD SAY
BEFORE HE WAS FINALLY ELECTED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
BECOMING THE FIRST WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE- BOARD. BY BEING
BY. SEVENTY NINE. WELL IN THE
LOS GROUP. MS WATER FIERCELY AB
FOR THE INTEGRATION OF LOS
ANGELES SCHOOLS MS WALTERS WAS
AN EARLY ADVOCATE OF SCHOOL
INTEGRATION AT A TIME WHEN THE
MAJORITY OF AFFORDABLE SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS WERE RELUCTANT TO
A LOT. ME FORM OF ANY. AND LOS
SYSTEM MS WALTERS A LONG TIME
CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATE WORKING.
INCLUDE. AND IT CAN DOUBLE BASS
C. P. SHE ALL TAUGHT ADULT AGE
CORPS. AND IN. AS A SECOND.
CLASSES WATCHED BEING ELECTED
TO LOTS ARE SCHOOL. FOLLOWING
HER STORE ON THE LOSS IN BOARD
SHE MAY HISTORY AGAIN AND I
NINETY WHICH BECAME THE FOR
BLACK WOMAN ELECT TO LOS CITY
COUNCIL. SEAT I BET YOU TOLD
THOUSAND ONE AFTER LEAVE
LAWCENTER CITY SHE WANTED TO
LOOK LOS ANGELES LIBRARY. WORKS
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS. MS WHAT
BELIEVE THE ALTARS BELOW IN THE
POWER OF IT CATION AS A WAY TO
TRANSFER PEOPLE'S LIVES. AND
FOUGHT HARD FOR RESEARCH AND
EQUALITY. MS WALTERS WE BE RE
FOR TO. STRONG WE HER CARE SHE
WAS OUTSIDE MY TOURS. AND
QUALITIES THAT WERE NOT NOTE BE
FOR EVERY BY. TO COME I'M SO WE
ADJOURN IN THIS GREAT CAL. HE
MISSED EFFORT MENACE LOTS. CITY
LIFE ANGELES SHE WAS SHE WAS IN
GREAT LEADER. SENATOR HILL ARE
YOU PREPARED. ALL I SO I'M
SORRY SO MITCHELL PLEASE. MY
APOLOGIES CENTER HILL. ELI THE
MEAN TO BE RUDE BUT I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF REP MISS BOTH OF
WHEN I CERTAINLY SOME AND
SENATE SO I FELT CA TO STAY
ALSO IN HER HONOR A MINUTE YOU
WERE I HAD THE I TO INTRODUCE
YOU ALL TO HER BECAUSE WAS MY
TWENTY SIXTEEN UNSENT HERE ON
WE ARE. OUR ARMED ME SAY WOMEN
ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS. HE WAS
ONLY A STORE ALL OF. HERE BUT
WAS ALL A TRUE TO OR WHEN I
FIRST. THIS TO RUN FOR THE
STATE ASSEMBLY SHE WAS ONE OF
THE FOR PEOPLE I AND SHE WAS.
IN G. IN CAO. OR SUPPORT IN HER
AND I SHE WAS MOTHER OF THREE
SHE SAID FIVE BY. TWO OF HER TO
BRING SUIT TO A- HER HERE AND
FLOOR THAT DAY WELL AS HEARST.
NAY A DULL ADULT SONS HELLO.
WAS A BROUGH. I'M BETTER AT AND
THE KIDS IN MY CAMPAIGN TWENTY
IN AND SO NOT WILL THE- CITY A
LAS PAN. THE RELATIVE SMALL
COME OF OUR AMERICAN WOMEN WHO
SERVED. THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL
FOR SHARING THAT SENATOR HILL
THANK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE. TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DANIEL
CHOSE OF SILVER. AND EIGHT OF
SAN FRANCISCO WHO WAS RESIDING
IN THE CITY OF VALLEJO AT THE
TIME OF HIS DEATH THE WITH THE
COMMUNITY LEADER A DAUNTLESS
ADVOCATE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE. IN
MY WILL TIME FOR. THEN I
ATTENDED- BALBOA HIGH SCHOOL.
WHERE HE WAS A GREAT ATHLETE
AND OF COURSE HUGELY POPULAR.
DAN WAS ALSO MUCH MORE. WAS A
THOUGHTFUL INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD
THE TWIN GIFTS OF UNDERSTANDING
AND COMPASSION QUALITIES THAT
ALREADY WE'RE CLEAR WHEN DâN
WAS IN HIS TEENS. NAME TO MR
FOOTBALL IN HIS SENIOR YEAR.
DâN RESPONDED WITH I THANK YOU
THAT RECOGNIZE THE KIND
SENTIMENTS OF OUR CLASSMATES
AND THE VALUE OF HIS ENTIRE
HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE HE SAID.
ALTHOUGH HAS DONE A LOT FOR ME
THIS IS A- NEVER FOR YOU. AND
ATTENDED CITY COLLEGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR A FEW SEMESTERS
BEFORE VOLUNTEERING IN THE ARMY.
HE GRADUATED FROM THE FAMED
EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE DIVISION
KNOWN AS AMERICA'S GUARD OF
HONOR. IN THE ONE HUNDRED FIRST
AIRBORNE. IT WAS THE MID
SIXTIES AND DAN WAS SENT TO
VIETNAM. HE SUFFERED INJURIES
THREE TIMES. THE THIRD INCIDENT
OCCURRED EASTER SUNDAY IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX WHEN A
GRENADE BLAST TORE INTO HIS
LEFT KNEE HIP ARM AND BACK. FOR
HIS SERVICE DâN RECEIVED A
PURPLE HEART WITH AN OAK LEAF
CLUSTER OF VIETNAM SERVICE
MEDAL AND THREE BRONZE STARS IN
SEVERAL OTHER MILITARY HONORS.
APPROVED IN COMBAT THAT HE WAS
A MAN OF INTEGRITY AND COURAGE.
HE ALSO PROVE THIS TIME TIME
AFTER TIME THROUGHOUT THE REST
OF HIS LIFE. AS A CHAMPION FOR
HUMAN DIGNITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE IN THE SEVENTIES. DâN
BECAME THE DIRECTOR OF CHEN
THROW COMBO. IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
MISSION DISTRICT. THE COMMUNITY
BASED TO SUB TO BOOST PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE LEADING HOSPITAL. CHARITY
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
EXPAND THE SERVICES THEY
OFFERED. IN DOING SO CONTROL
ALSO BECAME A FORCE THE SOCIAL.
IN THE CITY. BUT ALSO IN THE
SEVENTIES DâN LED THE MOVEMENT
TO CREATE SAN FRANCISCO'S
OFFICE OF CITIZEN COMPLAINTS.
THE CIVILIAN UNIT IN CHARGE OF
INVESTIGATING MISCONDUCT COMP
COMPLAINTS AGAINST CITY POLICE
OFFICERS. DâN WAS APPOINTED
CHIEF OCC INVESTIGATOR IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR A TOUGH
JOB THAT HE UNDERTOOK
WILLINGLY. BUT DâN RESIGNED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE TO PROTEST
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT'S
RESPONSE TO THE BEATING OF
LABOR LEADER DELORES HUERTA.
SHE SUFFERED A RUPTURED SPLEEN
AND BROKEN RIBS WHEN A RIOT
SQUAD CLEAR THE STREETS OF
DEMONSTRATORS WHO WERE HOLDING
A LAWFUL POLITICAL PROTEST
OUTSIDE A UNION SQUARE HOTEL.
NO CRIMINAL OR DISCIPLINARY
CHARGES WERE FILED THE PUBLIC
OUTCRY OVER THE CASE LED TO
REFORMS IN POLICE POLICY ON
CROWD CONTROL AND THE PROCESS
FOR OFFICE JUST IN. DANCE
ENGINE TO LOOK THE OCC ON
PRINCE. ONE HIM ACCOLADES
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND FREE SPEECH
ACTIVIST FIRST AMENDMENT
ADVOCATE DANIEL ELLSBERG CALL
DAN. A NEW HERO OF MINE. THEN
WENT ON TO WORK WITH THE
BERKELEY POLICE REVIEW
COMMISSION AND THE OAKLAND
CITIZENS POLICE REVIEW BOARD HE
ALSO HELPED FELLOW VETERANS
DâN SERVED AS THE CONSULTANT.
AND COORDINATOR FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO SWORDS TO PLOWSHARES.
AND DOWN FOR HOMELESSNESS IN
NINETY ONE. MOVE OP ED PLIGHT
OF HOMELESS VETERANS PUBLISHED
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO EXAMINER
THAT SAME YEAR DâN WROTE. AND
HOW TRUE IT IS TODAY. THERE IS
NO ALL NO DIGNITY AND IT WERE
HOMELESSNESS IS ACCEPTED. MY
FRIEND THAT DâN DIED ON
FEBRUARY ELEVENTH TWO DAYS
AFTER I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
VISIT HIM AT FORT MILEY
VETERANS HOSPITAL IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS SURVIVED BY RAQUEL
LEON SILVA IS SPOUSE AND BEST
FRIEND. THEIR TWO DAUGHTERS.
AND THEIR PARTNERS AND THREE
GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A CHURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
DANIEL STILL. I THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER HILLS THERE ARE MORE
LOCK THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
I WOULD. LIKE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF WALLACE DO EAT LAN
ALSO KNOWN AFFECTIONATELY AS
WALLY LYNN- COLLEAGUES HE- WAS
BORN ON FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE ANY PASSED
AWAY THIS MONTH ON FEBRUARY
FIRST. HE LOST HIS TWO YEAR
BATTLE WITH MULTIPLE MYELOMA AT
HOME WITH HIS WIFE VICKI AND
THREE OF HIS CHILDREN AT HIS
BEDSIDE IN APPLE VALLEY
CALIFORNIA- I SPENT MOST OF HIS
LIFE IN. MY AREA ORANGE
COUNTY'S I WANT TO THANK THE
PRESIDENT FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. HE WAS
BORN AND REARED IN MOUNT UNION
PENNSYLVANIA WHERE HE GRADUATED
FROM CAPTAIN JACK HIGH SCHOOL.
HE WENT ON TO ATTEND PENN STATE
COLLEGE AT SHIPPENSBURG AND
GRADUATED FROM PACIFIC COAST
BANKING SCHOOL AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON IN
SEATTLE. HE PROBABLY SERVED SIX
YEARS IN THE MARINE CORPS
RESERVES HE MARRIED HIS WIFE
VICKI ON MAY FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY. AND WAS LOOKING
FORWARD TO THEIR FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY THIS MAY. HE WAS A
REAL ESTATE BROKER. FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE TO THE
PRESENT HE SPENT MOST OF HIS
BUSINESS CAREER AS A BANKER.
SERVING AS A BRANCH MANAGER AND
A SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT. HE WAS
ALSO PRESIDENT OF AN
INDEPENDENT BANK THAT HE
ORGANIZED ORANGE COUNTY KNOWN
AS NEW CITY BANK IN THE-
ORANGE. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BALI AND VICKI SPONSORED A
FAMILY OF FIVE VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES WHO LIVE WITH THEM FOR
SIX MONTHS. AND THEY BECAME
FAMILY WE GOT TO SEE THEM EVERY
SUNDAY MORNING- FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO WHEN THE- FIRST WILL
BE ABLE TO THE BOAT PEOPLE CAME.
IN IT WAS KINDA UNTIL. THE
WORDS. IRAQ WITH THE THIS NEW.
GROUP OF IMMIGRANTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THE FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO BE INVOLVED IN
COMMITTED AND HELPING THE
COMMUNITY HE SERVED AS A
COUNCIL MEMBER. AND MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF A PALM A CALIFORNIA
IN FACT WAS MAYOR. AT THE TIME
I RAN FOR. COUNTY TREASURER. HE
WAS ALSO- WORKING A WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY LEAGUE OF CITIES
AND WAS READY TO BE THEIR
PRESIDENT. HIS PUBLIC SERVICE
INCLUDED THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
REPRESENTATIVE. HE WAS A FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE OF MY OF WHAT
ONE OF ONE OF MY FRIENDS SAN
MARINO COUNTY FORMER SAN MARINO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR BRAD. METS
AND FELT AND MOST REYES THIS
BILL REPRESENTED PER COPY I'M
PAUL OKAY. HE SERVED ON MORE
THAN TWENTY NINE. BOARD
SOMETIMES MANY TO THIS TIME.
RIGHT LUNCH WITH WHEN I WAS A-
MAN YOU REAL MENTOR BUT I'D
WALLY. TEN BOARDS COME. POPULAR
TO DO. SOME OF THE PUBLIC
SERVICE INCLUDE CHRIS CREDIT
CAN IN OUR WHICH SPRUNG OUT OF
A NEED THAT THAT CAME WHEN HE
WAS DOING AS A RADIO PROGRAM
CALL IN SHOW ON WHAT'S CALLED
QUE BRIGHTER K. B. R. T. OUT OF
LOS ANGELES IT WAS LET'S ABOUT
MONEY WHAT PLANET YOU PEOPLE
WERE CALLING OUT ABOUT IT YET
HOW DO I DEAL WITH THESE
SITUATIONS THAT I WOULD FOLLOW
HIM AS CHAIRMAN OF THAT
ORGANIZATION. SOME YEARS AGO.
HE SERVED AS A CHURCH DEACON AN
ELDER IN WAS ON THE BOARD OF
THE POLICE ATHLETIC LEAGUE IN
APPLE VALLEY. DURING HIS FORTY
YEARS IN FOUR DIFFERENT QANTAS
CLUB SEE SERVICE PRESIDENT AND
DISTINGUISHED PAST PRESIDENT
AWARDS INTO CLUBS. HE WAS GIVEN
SPIRIT OF AWARD FROM THE CITY
OF HOPE AND HE WAS BESTOWED IT
ACTOR TO. MAINE LET I'M AMERICA
CHRISTIAN UNIVERSE. VERSION
SERVICE HE WAS HONORED TO BE
THE FINANCED FOR THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE BILLY GRAHAM
CRUSADE IN OUT AND- WE ALSO
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
CHRISTIAN RESEARCH. INSTITUTE
INSTEAD HE- TO YOUR- THAT PROP.
MARK IN THE COMMUNITY WAS THE
NUMBER OF PRAYER BREAKFAST THAT
HE WOULD- SPONSORING GET
INSPIRATIONAL SPEAKERS FOR AND
WE WOULD PRAY FOR OUR CITY
COUNTY STATE FEDERAL LEADERS HE
WAS A MENTOR HE WAS A FRIEND.
MANY CAME TO MIND I DIDN'T
SUFFERING FROM CANCER MISTER
PRESIDENT. WE CAME TO MIND JUST
THE- A FEW WEEKS AGO AND I
THOUGHT I'M GONNA CALL IN TO
SAY HEY BANKS WHEN I WAS A
COLLEGE KID WHEN I WAS A YOUNG.
YOU INVEST TIME IN ME. HIS WIFE
TEXTED ME SAYING FOR THE
WONDERFUL VOICE MAIL. HE NEVER
GOT TO HEAR IT HE PASSED AWAY
JUST A FEW HOURS LATER- SO- YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST GREAT TO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT INVEST IN YOUR
LIVES AND WALLY LYNN WAS ONE OF
THOSE HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE VICKI HIS CHILDREN FIVE
GRAND CHILDREN AND- CHILDREN.
SO FIVE. OF MISTER PRESIDENT
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ADJOURN AND
WALLY LENDS MEMORY. THANK YOU
SIR MORE LACKEY AND- HE WAS HE
WAS A GREAT GUY AND THAT WAS A
GREAT TRIBUTE SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT. CENTER BURKE- THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY S. THAT WE
ADJOURN. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. IN MEMORY OF THE MOST
VENERABLE PIC CUANDO THE FIFTH
SUPREME PATRIARCH OF THE
UNIFIED BUDDHIST CHURCH OF
VIETNAM AND LIFETIME ADVOCATE
OF DEMOCRACY LIVE READING IN
HUMAN. AFTER THE FALL OF SAIGON
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE THE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT VIETNAM
BEGIN STRIPPING AWAY RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM AND RIGHTS. GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTED A STATE SPONSORED
FORM OF BUDDHISM AN OUTLAW ALL
OTHER CHURCHES- THE MOST
VULNERABLE THE TECH THOUGH WAS
THE CHAMPION OF HUMAN RIGHTS
AND BECAUSE OF HIS ADVOCACY HE
WAS IMPRISONED FOR TWENTY YEARS
MUCH OF IT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. HE ALSO WAS EXILED
IN UNDER GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS. OF TERRIBLE TO CUANDO
PASSED AWAY ON FEB TWENTY
SECOND IN VIETNAM. IN HUMAN.
ADD KIDS AROUND THE WORLD.
EARLY IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE LARGE VIETNAMESE
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
REMEMBER HIM AS A TRUE CHAMPION
OF HUMAN RIGHTS AND THE PEOPLE
OF VIETNAM. YES WE ADJOURN
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER BURKE. THE. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU- FOR
THE WORK THIS WEEK HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND IN YOUR
DISTRICTS WITH YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR FAMILIES
AND WE WILL RETURN IN AND I
WILL SEE ONE DAY MARCH SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. PM SAID IT
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE HERE ON
MONDAY. THE PM MEMBERS HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND.